brett is in columbia south carolina
hi brett welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing today
better than i deserve sir how can chris
and i help
uh well actually this is a a sensitive
subject
um me personally my me and my wife we
we're on baby step two we've paid off
about fourteen thousand dollars
um so far into our debt we're like
halfway done good
and uh we should be done with baby step
two
in june which is gonna be my birthday
present and then we'll you know move on
to three
but the question that i have today is
regarding my in-laws and uh
i called into the show once i got all
jumbled up so i wrote everything down
here so if you don't mind i'll just
go through it real quick if you don't
mind sure okay so
i'm concerned that my in-laws lack of
financial planning and discipline will
ultimately become my family's burden
they have the means to do well but not
the knowledge or discipline at the
moment
they're emotional not logical they know
there is a problem but number one won't
admit it
and number two will get upset or feel
belittled by me
if i were to express my concerns
how do i help them how do i have that
conversation with them
how do i make it seem like it's kind of
like their own idea rather than me
telling them what to do
and how do i get them started with uh
financial peace university
um how long have you been married uh me
and my wife have been
together for ten years married for three
okay
and through the majority of your married
life
you pretty much were like your in-laws
yes exactly so how would someone talk to
you
uh i mean i guess it would just have to
be a
kind of an upfront situation i uh well i
mean what what what
happened to you why did you change well
i
i guess it was because i i just got
tired of seeing you know that
35 non-sufficient fund fee because i had
no idea where my money was going it was
and then you
googled and found dave ramsey or what uh
actually it was my uh my work offered
the dave ramsey program
for a year for all of its employees and
uh
i started it but i didn't actually get
into it
and so a couple years later
i had that epiphany moment where it was
just like you know i'm just
i'm tired of living this way i make too
much and i do too well to
live this way and that's when i
remembered the program
and so i looked it up and actually
bought the program myself and um
that was my investment
brett let me ask you this buddy what's
your relationship like with your in-laws
are you guys close or somewhat close
we're really close we've uh you know
like i said i've
i've been uh i've been knowing them for
about 10 years now so
uh you know me and her dad go hunting
and
you know i think you've got an excellent
opportunity
to have conversations in love and what i
mean by that
is not necessarily telling them what
they need to do
but talking about what you've done and
what you and your wife are doing and
what it's doing for your relationship
see too many times we start off and we
want to have one conversation
and that's not that's not that's a start
that's an introduction
i would have just a series of
conversations with him
from the heart man to man your wife can
do the same thing with her mom
but let him know you're there to help
the crazy thing is
dave's been doing this stuff for 30
years knowing what works but then you
have people that won't do it
until they get ready to do it there's
people in my family
yeah and i'm freaking dave ramsey
i mean think about that think about that
yes
so you can't control them you can't
control you can't make grown-ups not be
stupid but
what you can do is talk about what
happened to you no one can really debate
your story
what did you do and you can just say man
i was this way and i was tired and i was
sick and tired of being broke i was sick
of those 35
things and they had it at my work and
then a half butt did that
and i blew that off and then finally i
hit the wall and this is what happened
man we paid off 14 000 we're gonna be
debt free by my birthday i'm just so
excited and
you know you just all you're doing is
just telling your story you don't have
don't say a word
about how stupid he is right right
just let him like because he he'll
figure that part out you don't have to
teach him that
he got it because if he'll give you
he'll give you an opening line and it'll
say something like
yeah man i wish i could do that really
do you really because man i would be
honored to help i'd be honored to get in
financial peace university i'd be your
biggest cheerleader man
if you'd work on it because i really
think you guys could go big man and it's
working for us but i mean whatever you
want to do but if you want some help man
oh god
don't don't don't don't wish cause the
genie will come out of the bottle man
i wish here he comes you know right but
don't but if he just looks at you like
you're dumb
don't say another word right just talk
about your story
and you have to be real careful talking
to other people's parents anyway so
probably
she is going to have more influence with
her parents than you ever will
now hear this too brett you're always
going to be an outlaw yeah and you
talking about your story is not bragging
that's fact you're talking about the
facts of what you all have done
yeah right and that's and see i've i've
had similar conversations and it wasn't
a bragging thing it was more of like you
know kind of
just like you said you know just trying
to kind of but if they don't if they
don't take the bait
you can't help them man because yeah
they blame it on that i have a
better job yeah yeah well here's what
here's the thing here's the thing you
got
pretend like they're not your in-laws
just pretend like they're friends of
yours they're a little bit older
right how would you convince a friend
well you wouldn't get all up in your
friend's business
you would be persuasive and you wouldn't
be
finger wagging that's right with your
own friend and so don't use your
father-in-law voice uh use your i've got
a friend
who's i wish he had more hope i wish he
didn't have such a victim mentality i
wish he
i wish he would do this stuff and how
can i help my friend have some hope how
can i
do that if you'll just change that voice
in your head it changes the words you
use no it does that's a good
that changes the narrative too i mean
just in the approach
and then bret you and your wife having a
conversation about what you guys can
control and that's you
what are y'all willing to do and what
are you willing not to do
and i think that bond is going to be
absolutely crucial
you know uh for you guys to stay on the
same page yeah i'm the generation now
that i've got
all my friends have grown kids right and
most of them got grandbabies
and so we've all had the conversation my
friends my you know my 60 year old 55
year old friends
it's like you can't make your kids
behave
you know what about this kid's doing
that that kid's doing that and these are
34 year olds you're talking about you
know
and you go well if you use your dad
voice on them
it shuts down everything yeah but if you
just sit down have a conversation
as a friend um you approach it
differently
the likelihood of them hearing it
increases but it's really all
it's the only thing you got left it's
the most frustrating stage of parenting
because it's the only stage of parenting
where you can't tell them what to do
yeah i was reading some books and it
says don't use the word
should because don't should on people
because when you should on them what
happens is they get defensive and i
thought whoa i'm gonna write that down
i need to tweet it that's a quotable
quote i know that's one that you you're
gonna steal it before i get it down i'm
gonna steal it or i'm going to
do it right now this is the dave ramsey
show